in 2014 Gloria alvarez became one of the
best-known libertarian personalities in
Latin America after she gave a talk
arguing against populism on the left and
right and pointing out the absurdity of
widespread admiration for the socialist
dictatorships in Venezuela in Cuba las
Mira's young TEM pices como el NiO por
el regimen Cubano por la semaine been a
Solano es absurd ah muy poco son los wat
a mistake oh no centroamericana yo
latinoamericano ZN general cave n en
louis regiment a vista las a TRO cidades
las relaciones a los derechos case estan
comity ando por que todo lo que pueden
ver a ocasion gratis hi salud gratis
Nara is gratis the 35 year old
granddaughter of Cuban and Hungarian
refugees is the host of the program free
Fridays on the Guatemalan radio station
liberty' Palace and she's the author of
several books including the populist
deception how to talk to a progressive
and how to talk to a conservative i sat
down with Alvarez at a conference in
Latin America put on by The Reason
Foundation in Guatemala City to talk
about the resurgence of socialism in the
region reaching young people with
libertarian ideas and why she believes
that cultural political economic and
sexual freedom are all intertwined and
non-negotiable
[Music]
Gloria Alvarez thanks for talking to
reason in Guatemala now you run a radio
show on Libertad bless you you're gonna
run for president when you reach the
official age you're an outspoken
advocate for libertarian values of
political economic cultural sexual
freedom in Latin America we're gonna
talk about all of that but before we do
explain how you got into libertarian
ideas where where did that come from in
your life well half of it is because my
family is a communist Runaways from Cuba
and Hungary so I always knew that
totalitarian regimes don't work but that
didn't make me a libertarian I chose to
study International Affairs and
political science because I wanted to
defend people but I didn't want to
become a lawyer because you know it's
boring to be a lawyer in Latin America
and I stumble upon
ufm without knowing that it was like a
libertarian safe-haven maybe if I would
have gone to the University Francisco
marroquín and Guatemala City yes but I
didn't know what classical liberalism
was I just chose that University because
it offered the the career that I wanted
maybe if I would have gotten to you know
a normal state university I would be
Marxist today and there I was confronted
with the free market economics which at
first I was very acceptable off but once
I understood philosophically the
importance of Liberty and you know
regarding individual rights as the core
of society I said okay this this can
work but I still was accepting all that
Guatemala was ready for them and then I
went and getting scholarships I studied
in the u.s. in Europe I was confronted
with the other side of ideas like
socialist Marxist ideas in Belgium in
Italy and I did some work with African
immigrants in Europe and I start seeing
the common line between people wanting
to have a better life so that's where I
got convinced that definitely Liberty
works and when I went back to what Amala
I started being very outspoken about
this on the radio and I started to
become you know
renown for that one of the things that
is striking I'm both in the libertarian
world in general but especially in a
kind of Latin American context is you're
outspoken about social issues as well as
economic issues because a lot of Latin
American libertarians will talk about
what we need free markets but then they
tend to be conservative in social issues
or they just don't talk about it
why why are social issues and cultural
issues so important to you because when
I went back on air in Guatemala and I
started talking with young people I
noticed that the lack of self esteem and
believing in yourself and emotional
intelligence and being resilient was the
key of why young people rejected free
markets you cannot convince people of
free economies if at first they feel
afraid of being free so I started
noticing that psychologically we have a
culture that it embraces you to be a
victim to find in others the guilt of
why you are poor or why you're not
achieving whatever you want to achieve
there's also a component of not
disturbing Society of not speaking up if
you speak if you think differently so
that's why for me social issues are so
important
you're a great equal opportunity
offender you haven't you talked at
conservatives as well as ads that
left-wingers what is different how do
you approach a conservative to convince
them that libertarian ideas make sense
and how do you talk to a socialist
so with the Socialists it's all about
the Socratic method instead of me
telling them why am i right I try to
question them on why their project is
good and once I do that I force them to
go back into the logical stream of
whatever they're proposing so for
example they say let's take away from
the rich to give to the poor okay but
how does that work
why would you take what is the list of
goods that you would make the government
give versus the ones that would be
private and that's where they get like
caught up with the Conservatives
you have to convince them of is that
free-market economics is not enough and
that there are there are things that
they defend out of dogma and what is
happening in Latin America is that the
left-wing is grabbing some flags that
appeal to young people like the gay flag
the environment flag the feminist flag
and conservatives think that just by
ignoring these subjects they will
disappear and they are not we're just
losing young people to the socialist
side what how as a libertarian how do
you engage things like gay rights the
environment and feminism just to mention
the things that you brought up well
first of all for the environment I I am
a strong supporter and I have get
involved in a market solutions for
pollution so I believe that it's not
only like I don't know about the climate
change because I'm not an expert but it
is evident that we're polluting the
planet so I for example started a
reforestation movement in 2012 that it
became self sustainable selling
forestation plans to different companies
so they could get like you know it tax
exemptions or something like that I
promote ideas that come from the market
to you know better the environment I I
never talk about like the government to
be the solution what I notice is that
the Conservatives don't use these market
solutions for pollution in their speech
but when you appeal to young people with
them they get interested with feminism I
go back to individual rights regardless
of your gender you have three individual
rights life liberty and private property
which are coincidentally their three
rights that are not guaranteed in Latin
America so my approach is if we will
have these three rights covered any
woman or man or gay man or whatever
could overcome the lack of opportunity
what are what are the worst places in
Latin America for kind of individual
freedom and liberty and what are the
best places I think that all the
countries in Latin America have a lakota
me [ __ ]
in the capital cities so if you go to
when Osiris or Madrid or Sao Paulo or
Mexico City or even Guatemala City
you're gonna see more respect for women
for the indigenous people for gay people
but if you go to the rural areas
you're still gonna encounter a very
machista backwards mentality where you
know women rights are not respected or
where there is racism and classism still
are there are there bright spots I mean
beyond the cities are there particular
countries or governments that are doing
good things or or are there I don't know
groups of people who are really kind of
making a difference I think it's um it's
not all black and white because what
really intrigues me is that the richest
countries of Latin America once they hit
some economic development like the case
of Cuba which was the richest country of
Latin America but not only that
culturally it was more open for women
for black people even for homosexual
communities and then they had the Castro
regime and everything was ruined then
you have Chile or even Venezuela
so what intrigues me is why the richest
countries of Latin America once they hit
this development they go backwards in
individual freedom
whereas poor countries like mine have
safe havens like UFM or leave a top
police radio it seems to me that when
you don't reach that level of wealth
people appreciate more individual
liberty what do you think explains that
dynamic of hitting a certain level of
wealth or comfort and then kind of going
socialist why why is that we have a
saying in Spanish it's like a poor
grandfather rich father miserable
grandson so what this explains is that
in three generations there's one person
that works hard to get out of poverty
the son of that of that father notices
how hard it was to work that but then
the grandson had everything given so he
doesn't remember like the hard times so
you have this
click Oh a neverending story yeah so
that's like Joseph Schumpeter talks
about that in his work you were gonna
run for president of Guatemala but
you're not old enough yet so good for
you because whether you have to be 40
right now you're under 40 good for you
let's pretend that you've ran and won
what would you be doing differently than
what's going on here first I would do a
reduction of the executive branch
instead of 14 ministries and 15
secretaries I would reduce it to four
making together things that I think
should work together like for example
only one ministry of resources with the
whole purpose of putting this back in
individual hands not the government
taking care of it and then I would do
tax decentralization so that each state
of Guatemala would be autonomous and
also 50 percent of the national budget I
would dedicate to the line of security
and justice because precisely what I was
telling you life liberty and private
property are the three rights that are
not respected in Guatemala so we need
strong judicial systems that take care
of the crimes once they are committed
until the final punishment is completed
and flat tax I think that if you reduce
a government to basic functions we'd
only want tax that it can be I don't
know the sales tax you can run the
machine what is the word what's the
worst part of the current Guatemalan
regime centralization in the capital
city I think the fact that there is some
mentality that the rest of the country
is so poor that they depend on the
capital so everywhere everything comes
here and that's why big corruption is
isn't closed here and this way you
cannot have individual development Latin
America similar to the United States had
has a youth boom a lot of young people
and a lot of old people and the old
people are growing more and more
dependent on the state for pensions and
things like that what are the big
you know what are the big points of
friction between the young and the old
in Latin America and how how is that
gonna play out one of the main
complaints that I get from other people
is how come young people don't remember
the eeper inflation dates of Mexico how
come people don't remember the parinita
era they complain that young people
became socialists but I also noticed
something that is that the old people
never took the time to sit down and
explain history and and you know by
storytelling to their sons and grandsons
in my case my Cuban grandparents made it
very clear for me you know like with
stories and because I also had family
that became communist back in Cuba so if
you don't talk about these issues young
people are never never gonna know about
them and for young people the main
complaint to the old is that they don't
modernize they say okay they might tell
me about free markets but they don't
want to talk about legalizing drugs and
homosexuality and you know like a more
globalized world they are stuck with
their traditions so I think that's the
main friction what are some other ways
to bring libertarian ideas to young
people in Latin America I mean part of
it is that the storytelling really
remembering the past and kind of talking
about that what are what are other
methods I think that we have to talk
about successful stories of that like I
am a true believer of what Hayek said
that if if you have elites with the
proper right ideas they will inspire the
rest of society I don't believe that
majorities change things it's always
minorities well-organized and with good
ideas so if we want to influence young
people we we have to know who are the
singers the songwriters the football
players the telenovela actors and
actresses that they follow and try to
persuade those leaders into having this
ideas which some of them are getting
like I'm pretty happy when like for
example Brad Pitt or Ricky Martin or
Antonio Banderas go on and complain
about the Venezuelan regime or how
capitalism like bono from u2
after decades of giving money to Africa
so they finally get it if they're
intellectually honest so I think we
should appeal to young people by their
hobbies or interests what what they like
you know the United's the United States
and Guatemala have a difficult history
of in the United States abetted horrible
things happening in Guatemala and that's
in many ways that's true of Latin
America more broadly what should the
relationship be between the United
States and Guatemala and Latin America
more broadly well first of all I think
that we have to own our [ __ ] I can't say
because no one comes inside your house
unless you let them so let me tell you
one example in what the money in the 50s
there was I don't know if you say it in
English inoculation of diseases in our
psychiatric hospitals in our jails
purposefully doctors from the United
States wanted to experiment with
syphilis and other diseases in Guatemala
so when the CIA opened this documents
all the left-wing of what the malla was
like oh my god this happened how
horrible until there were a document
signed by the left-wing
FDR of our era Juan Jose arrival
proving that the president who was a
socialist gave permission to the United
States to do this so first of all I
think that Latin America has to
understand that every time that the US
has get involved is because either the
government or the opposition or someone
inside the country said yes please come
in that's the first thing the second is
we need to have a better conversation on
how to open markets that would stop the
immigration to the US if people want to
live our countries we need to have
something that appeals for them to stay
so for instance if we legalize drugs a
new market of marijuana medicinal
marijuana tourism can start in Guatemala
so that people don't want to leave
we need to sell it that way and the
third I think it's foreign aid because a
lot of Americans with their best
intentions give money to some NGOs
without knowing that this NGO sometimes
financed the conflicts that make it
impossible for people to stay and have a
job is there the u.s. government beyond
the foreign aid question and should they
generally be not getting involved in in
Latin American politics or should it all
be through trade and culture as opposed
to anything else I think that the least
government interventions we have the
better what we need is more individual
contact for me for example is more
useful that for example in this
conference
I was wearing this what a modern typical
shawl and some women were like oh my god
where did you get that and I'm like oh
do you want to go to the lady that makes
it for me that kind of interaction is
wearing more useful in the long run than
our governments debating or dialogue in
because at the end they're only in
office for four years but individual
contacts that can last a lifetime
well we're gonna leave it there we've
been talking with Gloria Alvarez thanks
so much for speaking of reason points
for reason I'm Nick Lesley
[Music]